ein absolutes horror-szenario ein
atomunfall im belgischen atomkraftwerk
die experten und expertinnen bezweifeln
die sicherheit des atommeilers und das
schon länger und auf deutscher seite der
herstellung zwischen angst vor einem
atomunfall knapp 70 kilometer vom
umstrittenen belgischen kernkraftwerk
entfernt liegt daran und diana behörden
verteilen jetzt jodtabletten für den
fall des falles für einen atomunfall
eine absolut klasse maßnahme wer die
jodtabletten jetzt genau bekommt was sie
bei einem atomunfall bewirken und noch
weitere informationen zu diesem fall
jetzt den klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
sein anfang september läuft die jod
verteilung der behörden in aachen noch
bis ende november können die einwohner
in der nähe des dreiländerecks im
internet bezugsscheine für jodtabletten
beantragen und diese dann in apotheken
einlösen ein anrecht auf die kostenlosen
tabletten haben schwangere und stillende
und alle menschen bis 45 jahre zudem
muss man im stadtgebiet aachen und
offiziell gemeldet sein eine
vergleichbare verteilungsaktion gab es
bisher bundesweit nur in ausnahmefällen
und nur in sehr begrenzten region
absolut krass und den aachenern ist es
ernst zitat je nachdem wie das genaue
szenario aussieht haben wir ganz große
zweifel dass wir es schaffen
jodtabletten reiste rechtzeitig zu
verteilen das sagt der verantwortliche
koordinator markus krämer damit meint er
verschiedene faktoren die das
horrorszenario atomunfall maßgeblich
beeinflussen wann passiert der unfall
nachts oder tagsüber wie ist das wetter
gibt es starken wind und regnet es und
damit im worst case nicht auch noch
schnell und in panik ausgabestellen für
jodtabletten eingerichtet werden müssen
sorgt man in aachen lieber vor und zwar
nach der empfehlung der
strahlenschutzkommission denn die
empfiehlt für gebiete der außenzone für
den fall der freisetzung radioaktiven
jods infolge eines schweren
reaktorunfalls die verteilung von jod
tabletten eingenommen werden sollen die
tabletten aber nicht vorsorglich sondern
erst wenn die katastrophenschutzbehörde
dazu auffordert das alles sei eine reine
vorsichtsmaßnahme heißt es in einer
offiziellen broschüre der stadt trotzdem
sagt das schon echt viel darüber aus
wenn politik und verwaltung so eine
maßnahme für nötig halten wir haben hier
ja schon öfter über atomunfälle
berichtet und ihr alle kennt die fatalen
konsequenzen die ein störfall haben kann
doch was bringen in einem solchen fall
jodtabletten mediziner medizinerin
sprechen von einer sogenannten york
blockade die hochkonzentrierten jod
tabletten sollen also verhindern dass
sich radioaktives jod in der
menschlichen schilddrüse anlagert durch
die einnahme wird das normale nicht
radioaktive jod gespeichert die
schilddrüse ist gesättigt vom gesunden
jo die genaue dosierung ist für einzelne
altersgruppen genau festgelegt
erwachsene ab
46 jahren sondern allerdings keine
jodtabletten einnehmen denn hier sei das
risiko für schwere
schilddrüsenerkrankungen durch die
tabletteneinnahme sehr hoch höher sogar
als das erkrankungsrisiko das herrscht
wenn radioaktives iod aufgenommen wird
die städteregion aachen rät dieser
altersgruppe sich individuell
medizinisch dazu beraten zu lassen und
klar ist auch die jodtabletten schützen
eben nur die schilddrüse andere organe
können durch eine strahlenbelastung
trotzdem geschädigt werden mittlerweile
sind etwa 40.000 anträge für jeweils
einen aachener haushalt eingegangen
schätzungsweise wären damit rund 100.000
menschen mit jod versorgt anspruch haben
insgesamt etwa 600.000 menschen nach
angaben der behörde haben sich wohl
schon viele menschen vor der aktion
jodtabletten in den apotheken geholt
fest steht die arena haben angst und
sind mehr als verunsichert immer wieder
mal gibt es katastrophenübungen gegen
die drohende atomare verseuchung viele
halten die verteilung der jodtabletten
als noch nicht ausreichend auch
schutzkleidung gegen den radioaktiven
staub sei wichtig die aachener fordern
dass cios abgeschaltet wird denn nur das
sei ein effektiver schutz für die
bevölkerung doch bisher ohne erfolg
ihr problem wird nicht kleiner das
atomkraftwerk die rund 65 kilometer
hinter der deutschen grenze und in der
nähe von lüttich eigentlich ein
unscheinbarer kasten mit drei
druckwasser reaktoren gebaut ende der
60er jahre der erste block ist seit 1975
in betrieb doch die sicherheitssysteme
sind absolut überholt immer wieder kommt
es zu grösseren störfällen zu größeren
nach denen der reaktor für einige zeit
vom netz genommen wird 2012 wurden risse
in einem reaktorblock festgestellt 2014
explodierte ein transformator und 2002
kam es zur bislang schlimmsten störung
ein ventil stand einige zeit offen
der druck viel ab und das kühlwasser
verdampft eine kernschmelze wurde durch
die sicherheitssysteme verhindert
eigentlich hatte man sich in belgien
schon 2011 verständigt bis 2015 den
atomausstieg zu schaffen
doch berlin ist abhängig von der
kernkraft ohne sie droht stromknappheit
wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen
dann drücken wir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
nur dann werdet ihr auch neue über neue
videos informiert hier geht es weiter
mit super gau cernavoda schildere ich
den ablauf der tschernobyl katastrophe
wenn ihr da mal einen überblick haben
wollt ist dass das video der mann
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran